استدعاء وقياديين اصلاحين بتهمه التحرير
وابنه شقيقه خامنئي تحذر العالم من النظام
الايراني
182 مليار
و678 مليون
344000 دينار
رئيس الوزراء العراقيه
مليون دولار سرقت من الاموال الضريبيه
مع مصر ستبدا باجتماعا للوزراء لحل
القضايا الثنائي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير
من قاده التيار الاصلي
السابقين محمود صدقي
وبروانا سوري
عبر تويتر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فريده مراد خاني ابنته شقيقه النظام
الايراني
ان الايرانيين يخوضون حربا مع النظام
اي انسان
عن دعم هذا النظام قاتل الاطفال هذا
النظام لا يلتزم باي من المبادئ الدينيه
ولا يعرف قانون ولا قاعده للحكم سوى القوه
والمال ليحافظ على سلطته باي طريقه ممكنه
حان الوقت لتقوم جميع البلدان الحره
والديمقراطيه بحركه رمزيه عن طريق استدعاء
جميع ممثلين من ايران وترضي كل منتسب لهذا
النظام الوحشي كطريقه للتعبير عن التضامن
مع الشعب الايراني
[موسيقى]
على رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شيعه
السوداني عن استرداد 182 مليون دينار اين
نحو 124 مليون دولار سرقت من الاموال
ثلاثه مليون
و754 مليار
و642 مليون
و664 الف دينار عراقي
بالتعاقد مع شركه تدقيق عالميه هذا عمل
ثاني لزياده الاطمئنان حتى نعرف
مقدار المبالغ المسروق
تتابعون ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد
الفاصل
تركيا تصاحبها هجماتها في سوريا والاكراد
يتظاهرون احتجاجا على الصمت الدولي
اهلا بكم من جديد قال رئيس تركيا رجب طيب
اردوغان انه اعاده بناء العلاقات مع مصر
ستبدا باجتماع للوزراء لحل القضايا
الثنائيه
مع الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي في
قطر على هامش افتتاح كاس العالم استمر نحو
خمسه واربعين دقيقه مشيرا الى انه السيسي
كان سعيدين بهذا اللقاء واضاف اردوغان من
العلاقات مع سوريا يمكن ان تعود الى
طبيعتها مثل ما جرى مع مصر معتبرا ان
تركيا لديها حق التصرف خارج حدودها لحمايه
امنها
ميدانيه ذكر البورصه السوريه ان القوات
التركيه والفصائل الموالي لها قصفت
بالمدفعيه الثقيله مواقع لقوات النظام في
ريف الرقه الشمالي وقال المرصد ان القصف
طال قرى بريفيت تل ابيض الغربي شمال الرقه
دون ورود معلومات عن سقوط خسائر بشركه
وعلى وقع الهجمات التركيه تظاهر الاف
الاكراد في مدينه القامشلي مونددين بعمليه
وترددات انقره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الشيطان الشيطان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قال بترو كوتين رئيس شركه الطاقه النوويه
الحكوميه الاوكرانيه ان هناك مواصلات على
ان القوات الروسيه قد تستعد لمغادره محطه
النوويه
الروسيه قد تنقل سيطره على محطه
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه التابعه للامم
المتحده
ان تتحدث عن ان العسكريين الروس يحزمون
بالفعل حقائبهم استعدادا
الاوكرانيه بين سلطات البلاد تمكنت من
استعاده نحو 80% من الطاقه التي تلبي
احتياجات الاستهلاك ليبلغ العجز 20% فقط
اضافه الوكاله ان جهود استعاده الكهرباء
جاريه بعد الهجمات الروسيه المتكرره على
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في البلاد
[موسيقى]
اشاره صحيفه
نقلا عن مسؤولينا امريكيين قولهم بان دعمه
واشنطن لكيب عسكريه يوفر على تسليم
دفاعها عن نفسها ضد اي هجوم صيني
19 مليار دولار مما يؤخر جهود تصليح
الجزيره
ومره اخرى تظهر علنا ابنه زعيم الكوري
الشمالي كيم جونغ والتقت هذه المره بعلامه
مثل الطفل المحبوبه او الغاليه وتبلغ
ابنته من العمر حوالي 10 اعوام فقط لكن
صورها الجديده والجريئه تعمق الجدل حول ما
اذا كانت ستعد كخليفه لوالدها وفقا ياسر
[موسيقى]
ليبيا عبد الله بصيري في ابوظبي معه وزير
الدوله بوزاره الخارجيه الاماراتيه
والوصول للانتخابات وشدد طرفان على ضروره
التغلب على الازمه السياسيه وتمهيد الطريق
الانتخابات تمنح الشعب ممثلين شرعيين
على التنسيق مع مختلف الاطراف الدوليه
لتقديم الدعم الى ليبيا
وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري الاثنين
في القاهره وقالت الوكاله المصريه
اعلنت الشرطه الصوماليه التصدي
لهجوميشانته حركه الشباب على فندق في
العاصمه مقديشو يضم مطعما يحظى بشعبيه بين
المسؤولين الحكوميين
واوضح حتى الشرطه انها انقذت العشرات
بينهم مدنيون ومسؤولون فيما لم ترد اي
بيانات عن وقوع اصابات
بعيد عن القصر الرئاسي وسط العاصمه حيث
سمع دوي انفجار عقبه اطلاق نار
تونس تحت خط الفقر المائي ومواردها من
المياه صارت مهدده اكثر فاكثر السدود
التونسيه لا تحتوي الا على 27% فقط من
طاقه التخزينيه
غرب تونس واحد من السدود 37 التي تراجع
منسوب تخزينها للمياه بشكل كبير يعمل فريق
من وزاره الفلاحه التونسيه على اعاده
تاهيله بعد ست سنوات من الجفاف حتى ان
خليفه هذه السنه لم يكن سخيا سدود تونس لا
تحتوي الا على ربع طاقتها التخزينيه
تقريبا
مياه المخزنه بسدود هي في ادنى مستوياتها
قال باعتبار
سنتين فيهم عجز ايرادات لم تتجاوز 40%
سنويا اليوم حنفي 37 فيهم نسبه تعبئه ب
29%
وادي نشر ده اكبر وانهار تونس وشريان
ومياهن نابع من مرتفعات سوق اهراس
بالجزائر هكذا صار منصوب المياه فيها
وهكذا صارت وضعيه الحقول والزراعات
المحيطه بهيه
تبقى قنوات نقل المياه من محافظه يا زغوان
وسط تونس الى العاصمه منذ العهد الرومانيه
وفي فسقيته الاغاني في العهد الاسلامي
اكبر شاهد على تعاطي سكان تونس مع ازمه شح
المياه عبر التاريخ لكن الازمه الحاليه
خطيره جدا وغير مسبوقه وفقا المسؤولين
وتتطلب حلولا عاجله
[موسيقى]
المهندسين بتونس العاصمه اجتمع مهندسون
وخبراء في الموارد المائيه ووزراء سابقون
لبحث ازمه المياه بعد ست سنوات عجاف صار
فيها نصيب المواطن 400 متر مكعب من المياه
في السنه اي تحت خط الفقر المائيه بينما
كان الفا في السنه في الستينات القرن
الماضي الوضعيه خطيره والحلول العاجله
صارت اكثر من اكيده
في السبع سنوات الاخيره هنالك ست سنوات
جافه وهو مش شايف واحده ما يقلقش اكيد
تبدا اعوام جافه متتاليه هذاك هو تم
الاشكال وهذاك اللي يحثنا احنا قوي وزاره
نحاولوا باش نخططوا وباش نقسمه الماء وباش
نعله بين مياه الشرب ونياه الرجل
ان تونس ان لم تتمكن من حل مشكله مياه
الري مع بدايه السنه القادمه فستكون دون
مياه شرب الصيف المقبل وليد عبد الله
العربي تونس
حاله الطوارئ في جزيره ايسكا حيث ابتلعت
سيول جارفه عددا من المباني ووردت بحياتي
ثمانيه اشخاص ودفنا تحت اللوحام 10
المفقوده
في ختام هذه نشره تذكير بما جاء فيها من
الاخبار
العالم من النظام الايراني
182 مليون رئيس
124 مليون دولار سرقت من الاموال الضريبيه
واردوغان يعلن ان اعاده العلاقات مع مصر
ستبدا باجتماع للوزراء لحل القضايا
الثنائيه
[موسيقى]